gracias por estar con nosotros dice
crespo aquí en directo américa de france
24 y preguntó entonces qué significa que
un país salga de la hiperinflación en
términos sencillos bis
buenos días gracias por la invitación
bueno en primer término creo que es
importante
expresar la
diferencia con lo expresado por nicolás
maduro y las cifras que ahora el banco
central correa publicar luego donde
luego de muchos años donde el propio
banco además de perder su
institucionalidad les escondió las
cifras a los venezolanos y eso dio que
los espacios académicos tuviésemos que
crear mecanismos metodologías y formas
de poder este recolectar la información
y poder mantener a la población
informada este ojalá
el país a la brevedad pueda salir de la
hiperinflación un fenómeno altamente
destructivo en el cual la nefasta
política económica y la distorsión la
destrucción del sistema monetario nos
llegó este a partir del año 2017 estará
hiperinflación es estar sumergido en un
fenómeno de aumentos exacerbado de
precios en minutos en segundos soy de
los economistas y comparto la visión de
los colegas del observatorio venezolano
de finanzas de que estamos en el mes 10
de hiperinflación y que si deberíamos en
el primer trimestre de este año estar
fuera del fenómeno ahora luis le quiero
preguntar por qué se anuncia digamos por
parte del gobierno este fin de la
hiperinflación cuando el dato de
inflación acumulada anual fue de 686 por
ciento
hay una metodología de un economista fil
caga keegan premio nobel de economía que
establece que una economía que mantiene
por un año es valores de inflación por
debajo del 50% se reconoce que está
fuera del fenómeno de la hiperinflación
a partir de esa metodología es el banco
central y su cifra que generan alta
desconfianza
decreta el fin del fenómeno sin embargo
en los sectores académicos el
observatorio venezolano de finanzas que
ha sido este un equipo que ha venido
trabajando el tema de las cifras
macroeconómicas en el país reconoce que
estamos en el mes 10 estar por encima de
600 por ciento significa una inflación
muy alta nosotros en venezuela
quisiéramos estar fuera del fenómeno
quisiéramos que la estabilidad monetaria
vuelva al país pero por el contrario
este eso
sería el resultado de un plan
estructural del consenso que de una
manera u otra involucre a todos los
sectores si creemos que las medidas que
se están tomando de manera silenciosa
que
podemos proyectar ya que para el primer
trimestre del año pudiéramos estar desde
fuera el fenómeno la incertidumbre de si
estas medidas son sostenibles en el
tiempo y además este pueden garantizar
que en el 2022 podamos continuar
transitando por relativa estabilidad a
los niveles
louis qué pasa con la dolarización no
oficial del país también esto es una
causa por la cual se está viendo la luz
al final del túnel digamos
bueno en las cifras de pib que han
estado debatiéndose en las últimas en
las últimas semanas que hablan de la
posibilidad de un pib positivo para el
2021 o una menor caída con respecto al
2020 y que proyecta crecimiento para el
2022 es el resultado insisto de un
conjunto de medidas silenciosa un viraje
que viene esté
tomando la administración de nicolás
maduro en la dolarización
transaccional desordenada ha permitido
restablecer algunos equilibrios
microeconómicos quiero dejar claro que
esa polarización fue una respuesta de
los agentes económicos las empresas y la
familia no fue una política económica de
la administración de nicolás maduro por
el contrario la verdad la persiguieron
la estigmatizar y al final hoy en día la
reivindica pero fue la forma que
encontraron la familia venezolana y las
empresas que querían y deseaban seguir
operando en la economía venezolana
para poder mantener el equilibrio
microeconómicos para poder establecer
precios reponer inventarios establecer
su contabilidad reponer salarios para
garantizar el factor trabajo en medio de
un desastre y la destrucción del sistema
monetario no olvidemos que en venezuela
en menos de tres años se realizaron dos
reconversiones monetarias se eliminaron
11-0 en menos de tres años y eso es un
ejemplo para ilustrar un poco lo que es
la destrucción del sistema monetario
venezolano y la desaparición del bolívar
como signo monetario que genere
confianza retos económicos que va a
tener que enfrentar venezuela y el
gobierno de maduro a mediano y largo
plazo louis
el tema de la pobreza la desigualdad y
la inequidad esa luz que apareciera que
utilizas tu para presentar el tema es
pudiera significar una gran oscuridad
para una gran cantidad de venezolanos
que hoy se encuentran sumergido entre la
pobreza y la desigualdad más del 90% de
los venezolanos se encuentra tengo una
línea de ingreso entre en el cinturón de
pobreza
65 en el 65% de la pobreza en este
multidimensional el salario destruido
las condiciones de trabajo y la
seguridad social destruido el salario
mínimo en venezuela significa nada
aproximadamente el 1.5 por ciento y este
lo que observamos es una gran
desigualdad y no una y no observamos una
política que pueda dar respuesta a en el
corto plazo al tema del poder
adquisitivo de los venezolanos creo que
es fundamental discutir una metodología
que permita recomponer o reconstruir el
salario de los trabajo ahora es su poder
de compra porque estamos en una zona en
un país donde se amplía la brecha de
desigualdad y crece la pobreza alarmante
en nuestro país pues louis gracias por
su tiempo por su análisis para entender
un poco lo que está ocurriendo en
venezuela en términos económicos y está
pues digamos mediana salida a la
hiperinflación